on the road to Russ itch dear the street
is dusty and there are more and more
army and police checkpoints this is
where Tunisia's border to libya begins
next door lies a failed state where
chaos and violence rule just behind this
border so-called Islamic state is trying
to extend its power base only a few days
ago I as fighters tried to storm the
city of subrata which is about 80
kilometers from here
most of the is fighters are originally
from Tunisia and that's a major concern
not only for the border guards here but
for the government in Tunis the Tunisian
army and police are on high alert and
the country is in a state of emergency
last year Tunisia saw three major
attacks carried out by Tunisian fighters
who joined the Islamic state in Libya
during our filming at least border
patrols are very frequent many travelers
here have first-hand knowledge of
Islamic state terror across the border
it was between 3:00 and 4:00 in the
afternoon suddenly everything was empty
everything was closed they climbed onto
the roofs and began shooting the battles
lasted for more than three days on the
way to the border it was quiet there
were no problems at the checkpoint the
Tunisian Libyan border is some 460
kilometers long the government is
building a wall along the entire length
of it up until now militants weapons and
even cosmetics easily crossed back and
forth across the border many people in
small towns like Ben garden earned their
living by smuggling now the merchants in
the market near the main mosque are
complaining about their losses
supplies from Libya have dried up
profits are down by nearly half this man
says others complain that more and more
Tunisians are returning home because
they've lost their jobs in Libya there
are going to be more unemployed people
here when they all return we asked if
people's support is or will be drawn to
them here no no impossible they say not
here around six thousand Tunisians have
already joined the Islamic state
according to UN estimates we asked
researcher Alya
Aulani why he says that since the
Jasmine Revolution of 2011 when protests
brought down the former regime many
mosques have been recruiting fighters
for the war in Syria initially two
nested little to stop it in my opinion
Islamist government is the first
responsible for two development of the
Terrorism phenomenon in Tunisia because
this government he it haven't it hadn't
any program any strategy for the
security the current government has
promised Tunisians they'll do more to
guarantee security and combat terrorism
especially on the border
in Rus each dr3 ministers have arrived
from Tunis they're here to inspect the
new border facility that be some border
areas are still being built up but it's
already clear how important they are for
fighting terrorism we've made big
investments here in Rus each tier we are
now going to continue that for example
with a new fortified wall Tunisians are
afraid that the chaos in Libya will
spill over the border to them
you